today the prayer is the American people
are with the family of a devoted and
courageous journalist steven sotloff
overnight our government determined that
tragically Steven was taken from us in a
horrific act of violence we cannot even
begin to imagine the agony that everyone
who loves steven is feeling right now
especially his mother his father and his
younger sister so today our country
grieves with them like Jim Foley before
him Steve's life stood in sharp contrast
to those who murdered him so brutally
they make the absurd claim that they
kill in the name of religion but it was
Steven his friends say who deeply loved
the Islamic world his killers try to
claim that they defend the oppressed but
it was Steven who traveled across the
Middle East risking his life to tell the
story of Muslim men and women demanding
justice and dignity whatever these
murderers think they'll achieve by
killing innocent Americans like Steven
they have already failed they failed
because like people around the world
Americans are repulsed by their
barbarism we will not be intimidated and
their horrific acts only unite us as a
country and stiffen our resolve to take
the fight against these terrorists and
those who make the mistake of harming
Americans will learn that we will not
forget and that our reach is long and
that justice will be served